The Joe Rogan Experience when I was on
the Xanax it was basically during the
pandemic
I had ten thousand of those things at
the house ten thousand because he was
sending me 90 a month from 2012.
on automatic monthly
they were just going in the closet they
were just going in the [__] when did
you take it 2012 was what I got it
prescribed when I had my little
situation at The Comedy Store that we
goofed about that was none of that's not
that was not good
there's no way I should be understanding
walking 10 count
that's what that was that night when I
had to follow Morgan Murphy a standing
walking 10 count dog I want to I asked
Paulie Shaw I told you the story and we
laughed about it but dog now thinking
about it I should have done something
I went to The Comedy Store I'm in the
back you weren't there I think you had
you were coming in late yes you were
coming in later because on Saturdays I
used to do the close the original room
uh-huh talking bullshitting with Paulie
everybody's in the back no refill maybe
a joint before I got there you know
Saturday night just let the girls I get
there
they say Joey you're up next I walked to
the thing and as I'm walking
I walk up the steps to the original room
and Morgan's on stage and Paulie's
standing there laughing at her
and I walk up and I'm like damn I don't
[__] feel good
like this is not working
I was starting to get anxiety
I couldn't breathe I couldn't breathe
but I went to look at that window for
years whenever I had anxiety in the
original room I had a window
when I'm on stage I got a window on the
right remember yeah and we can look out
the sunset yeah I was always good that
day particularly when I went in there I
didn't see a [__] window
so I was waiting for Morgan to get off
and also I got this anxiety Joy I
couldn't breathe
I couldn't [__] breathe so I walked
down the stairs just to look at the door
to get and it got worse it got worse I
couldn't breathe I thought it was gonna
[__] have a heart attack
and I go poorly I can't get on stage I'm
having a horrible anxiety attack he goes
I just went up dude
and I walked up there and I told you but
I didn't explain it to you correctly or
because I was cracking a joke I woke up
at the 12 minute Mark hmm
I remember walking past Paulie and
that's it Joe
that's it and then I remember waking up
on stage and people laughing and I was
probably an automatic pilot wow I had a
bit that it was on automatic pilot it
was a little scary when you got on Xanax
no it was a couple weeks I went to the
doctor and he goes what was that I kept
having these little panic attacks
kept having these little panic attacks
little panic attacks but I was okay I
wasn't going to go to a psychiatrist we
were working our asses off we didn't
know what the [__] was going on so I
started taking the Xanax and it would
help it a little bit I would take it on
the road if I went on a plane or
something like that what does it do for
you you got to remember too it was you
were walking contradiction I'm talking
about myself because you said it best
I'm eating 2 000 milligrams of THC and
scaring the [__] out of myself right
you're walking around [__] scaring
then the Xanax I would take the Xanax to
calm me down off the anxiety
come on man that's not gonna work those
edible weed sessions when you do too
many of them I do think they make people
very anxious I think they just I think
they did the [__]
the pole of your brain you know I
brought some water but now I eat them
more to sleep I got them on a
my big problem Joe is still to this day
asleep
so now two nights three nights a week I
drink a bodybuilder
uh sleeping thing what do you do you
have a hard time sleeping because you're
not tired do you have a hard time
sleeping because you're thinking I'm
dying
till 9 30.
and I look come on man the comedy timing
I don't want to go to bed at 9 30. yeah
you know what I'm saying I never want to
go to bed at eight o'clock that's when
you know you're almost done yeah I want
a ballet [__] you man yeah I'm not
looking for stay up till four but I'm
not going to bed at 9 30. so I'm tired
about nine but I push the envelope a
little bit I had to read maybe listen to
music 11 11 30. I'm like you I like to
read [__] on the computer 11 11 I try to
read at night I turn the TV off
once I go up there bro
I'm thinking about the guy who came to
my house who asked me if he could take
an orange
but it's like three instead he took nine
he took nine instead yeah and you're
like that was 11 years ago Joey I think
about the time I bombed in the original
room following Dom my Herrera like does
it matter I think about the time I ate a
bucket of dicks in North Carolina in
Chapel Hill doesn't matter does it
really matter that you ate a bag of
dicks you know I I think it's stupid
[__] yeah and I fall asleep eventually
I'll tell you what helped whoop I got
the whoop watch to help me with recovery
because I was lifting and going to jiu
jitsu and my back would hurt so I wanna
I wanna figure out what kind of calories
I could do and I won't go over those if
I could do those five days a week that's
fine but I can't go in there burn 800
[__] calories in Jiu Jitsu and expect
the deadlift the next day I don't have
that so I got the whoop watch the whoop
watch put me on to sleep it's helped me
sleep better because I finally realized
go you slept four hours last night no
wonder you feel like [__] right so now
I'm in contest with whoops so I got it
up from four and a half hours of sleep
to eight hours pretty much last night I
only slept like five because of the
flight
but I'm sleeping eight hours now that's
great yeah now I'm sleeping 11 30 to 8.
don't get me wrong once every two weeks
I have a little hiccup
I go upstairs I think of something I go
back down I smoke some pot I read and I
go back up and I'm all right
but what I was doing comedy there was no
sleep Joe yeah do you want me to tell
you why why eight cups of espresso a day
you know everybody thought I would leave
the store because I was going to do
something bad you know I was leaving the
store before midnight
think
why because Starbucks is open till
midnight in Studio City and God forbid I
didn't catch my flat white before
midnight
God forbid I didn't catch my Grande flat
white before midnight and then I'll call
you tomorrow and tell you how I didn't
sleep last night so you were drinking
coffee late into that we would always
have espresso after dinner yeah no we
now I haven't expressed like five and
I'm not sleeping that's so weird I could
sleep right after having one oh I loved
it because in my world it takes you up
yeah so you catch it on the way down
I eat a chocolate something I can't
[__] sleep that night now really I
really focused on my sleep the last
couple years you know especially since I
got this whoop
about 16 17 months ago that's what's
really improved in my life is asleep and
I've been taking naps too if I go to jiu
jitsu I do the blue belt class I need a
nap check
I need a little nap from five to six you
know
that's where I am
but when I started popping the Xanax the
the pie point was maybe May of during
the pandemic
like I couldn't leave the house without
popping the Xanax and then when I get in
the car I pop another one
and it would stay in your system thank
God I wasn't drinking and what was that
doing for you though like what's the
feeling like calming me down
I can't take sleeping pills and I can't
take the strong Xanax so I have to take
the little footballs
but I was taking eight to ten of those
[__] a day Jesus and then when
I landed in Jersey what had happened was
you know how you and Tom had that
conversation about my tolerance yeah
okay that tolerance dog I think as you
could tell I think a lot about this [__]
yeah you had a conversation with me a
couple years ago about your Romero
getting punched in the face and his eye
socket and when he got into the Green
Room into the uh when he went to the
doctor saw him after the fight his eye
socket was healed it was healing healing
okay yeah
I think about what you were talking
about my tolerance with the Edibles and
stuff now let's get back to early Joe
Diaz
when I was a child the doctor would have
to come to my house two days in a row
for years
did I have to shoot me a penicillin on
Monday and then come back on Tuesday and
shoot me again because I would never
take the penicillin
you know I had a lot of problems with my
throat as a kid and uh whatever [__]
tonsils and [__] so I was always in the
hospital as a kid I was a sickly kid so
I was about eight
all those years Joe they would always
have to shoot me two or three times with
Penicillin the same penicillin they
would give you one shot of they'd have
to shoot me
so I don't know you've always had a high
tolerance always interesting except for
alcohol
um and even alcohol cause I could drink
something with Jamie right now and I
won't fall over I don't want to do it
but that's what's always pissed me off
about alcohol that I could drink a few
alcohol shots feel okay but then if I
push the envelope that's when I feel
shitty
but my tolerance with alcohol and with
cocaine and alcohol [__] I could take a
case of Budweiser you know cans
so my friend Johnny you wrote a Coke
problem I always used to have to take
him to the corner store or the liquor
store to get 40 ounces yeah he would
calm himself down with like a big Malt
Liquor it's always trying to like 20
something else 22 beers and it would
calm you down so when the Xanax finally
what I realized when I got to Jersey
that yeah I got the Jersey August 9th or
something on your bro August something
two days after I got the Jersey I had
something like a weird mild heart attack
my heart didn't stop pounding
and that was because the Xanax turned on
me
I didn't realize that till I went to the
knee surgery
and one of the assistants caught it
because I couldn't sleep when they tried
to give me something to sleep and the
chick goes you're you're a
withdrawing
oh from benzo she goes you're
withdrawing naturally that's why your
heart beats going up that's why you
[__] up it's very dangerous for that
she told me you have to flip it so I had
to read a
a journal about this about
transitioning you just can't quit you
can't quit alcohol and you can't quit
benzos yeah there's that uh you know you
could die so what I had to do was take
whatever I was eating which was eight of
those things a day and work myself
backwards how long did it take you
six months wow worked myself backwards
[__] tough to write man I'm sure you
know how it is with these [__] things
you got to dig deep in this point look
there's a lot of a lot of soul searching
too I'd imagine yeah no while I was
doing it I was [__] up as hell that's
why I figured I'd do it then you did it
while you were getting off the benzos
yeah well I was just I just moved I did
the knee surgery it was like a thousand
things I didn't even know I was
withdrawing like I said until I went to
I did the knee surgery and something
happened with my heart
and one of the doctors came in and we
started talking and he kept looking at
me weird he was a Spanish dude
and I [__] he gave me his card and I
called him when I got out and he goes
come see me something wasn't right that
night
he did a physical
and I went back to see him blood that
type of [__] and he goes everything was
right you know everything was okay
I don't know what he put me in a heart
monitor and he goes Charlotte's fine I
don't know what the [__] you're talking
about and his assistant
said are you still taking the Xanax and
I go yeah and she goes that's what's
going on with you
look at the charts doc he's been on them
since 2012 and so I go no I just been
using them since the pandemic started
and that's when she goes no you got to
stop withdrawn I didn't even know I just
had a horrible [__] feeling how long
do you think it takes when you're on
those things before you're addicted
two weeks maybe really well I didn't see
I would take them and then forget about
them I would put them in my top pocket
and then go to the store and not take
them and then I would just wash them
there was a lot of times I would take
them I would bring it with me in case I
got like a little [__] you know
but Joe the funny thing about this if I
tell you this goes back to when I was a
kid
in the simplest way you ready for this
I was a little [__] fruitcake when I
came from Cuba you know I sucked the
pacifier I thought I was six
so after like I was three they took them
away from you but I'd hide them in
strategic places
and whatever shit's got Danger
I go over something put it down and then
I [__] go back to what was going on
here so when I lived in 88th Street in
New York City my mom had a jukebox at
the bar so every week the guy comes in
and he gives you the old 45s is that
what they're called 45s so I don't know
what they were they were all different
type Spanish music you know black music
rock music my mother had a great taste
in that in the Jukebox so I would have
[__] boxes of singles I lived on the
third floor
and if you go to 205 305 West they even
today you pull up to it you'll see my
where I live where I grew up right down
the third floor but you'll see that
there's a like a parking garage there
they never really it's like an old
building now it's redone again they did
something when we were kids we played
back there
so whenever I had anxiety I would go
upstairs to suck on the pacifier I
didn't I didn't I wasn't cool enough to
put them on the street yet I would later
in time I would put him on the street
and I would suck on him when I was
playing basketball or something if
things that they called the foul on me
and I would panic
I would go upstairs and I had a window
that they couldn't see from below
because it was the back of the building
so it was like an indentation and all
our Windows you can't see that from
there so I would take those 45s and I
would whip them
they're like [__] boomerangs I would
just sit there for 10 minutes and just
whip them whip them whip them and I'd
hear people downstairs what the [__]
stop it you [__] scumbag what's going
on and then I run downstairs and all
these kids will be holding on to the
heads and [__] they're like where'd you
go and I go I went upstairs to go to the
bathroom you missed it the crazy guys
throwing records at us do you know how
long I did that before I did that for
about a year I threw records at those
[__] I cut them I did so many
things to those kids they never knew it
was me but back to it that's how I
started going upstairs to suck on the
pacifier
so I always had something you know what
I'm saying like I always had my little I
wanted something to like help you out I
always had some to smooth in the humps
and the bumps I didn't know that [__]
existed